today's topic
well guys there's a couple of clips
going viral from news coverage of the
war in ukraine and the reason so many
people i think are watching and reacting
to them is because they really seem to
give up the game on something really
central to the media's coverage of
ukraine
namely why are they so deeply concerned
for the victims of this particular
crisis in contrast to the indifference
or outright contempt displayed for the
victims of any myriad of other crises
around the world let's take a look
now with the russians marching in it's
changed uh the calculus entirely uh tens
of thousands of people have tried to uh
flee the city there will be many more
people are hiding out in bomb shelters
but this isn't a place with all due
respect
um
you know like iraq or afghanistan that
has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully too uh city where
you wouldn't expect that or hope that
it's going to happen that was you
choosing carefully and you still [ __ ]
up
you still [ __ ] the you that was you
that was you
watching what you were saying you was
actually calculating
how am i going to be able to say it that
it sounds good and that's the best you
could come up with
i'm sorry
sometimes when i hear people say
civilized like what did you think
libya was before foreign intervention
brown
what did you think iraq was before
foreign intervention syria brown again
all right like you guys are out here
funding rebels just doing insert you
guys are inserting yourselves in other
people's territories
right like if you think about it what
the us has done to a bunch of countries
either be it in africa or the middle
east is exactly what russia is doing in
ukraine
but i do find it very distasteful when
people say civilized like [ __ ] you
think europe is the only place with
civilization yeah
just because these civilizations don't
look like the ones that are familiar to
you by american front
it does not mean that they are not
civilized places i i don't i don't even
think it's because they look like it i
think that's just like stuff they say to
drum up sympathy from the people this is
all about money it always is about money
fair if you really think that these rich
people are like i want to save poor
white people you are bugging fair right
because at the end of the day because
when they're when they're duck they're
going to get the black kids yeah this is
this is just their opportunity to go up
against russia that's their thing so
they'll drum up any sympathy story that
they can absolutely it's like this kind
of rhetoric makes me cringe so hard and
one other thing is like america almost
lost its mind because they felt like
russians were meddling in their
elections
it's like [ __ ] you met on everybody
else's elections american will literally
just assassinate other people's
presidents okay this is not hearsay
these are documents you can look up
online that's known they will meddle in
everybody else's elections choose the
leaders that are most convenient to them
but then have a completely different
standard and what it really comes down
to is how they paint these narratives as
long as conducive to the agenda of the
folks who got the power they'll paint
whatever narrative to me i'm sorry it's
very emotional for me because i see
european people with blue eyes and
blonde hair being healed children being
killed every day with putin's missiles
i see white people getting killed so it
gets to me that's what it is that's what
he said that's what he said he said
white white the blue eyed and that that
sounds very familiar i think what's his
name who said that
yeah voldemort now the unthinkable has
happened to them and this is not a
developing third world nation this is
europe you know they talk like ukraine
is like this advanced societies like
[ __ ] ukraine is poorer than half of the
countries in ukraine in africa you know
what i'm saying like like you you're not
special it's not because it's white that
it's right okay it's not because it's
okay it's rich too there you go it's not
because it's europe that's right y'all
got a bunch of poor welfare countries
over there too y'all really think that
all the countries in africa all the
countries in africa have kids were
flying with flies most of them got
higher gdps in ukraine like get the [ __ ]
up out of here bro don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
with a butt no no bunch of these trust
me i know there's a bunch of poor white
countries because i like visiting them
do you know how good it feels with my
money now to go over there and be like
uh poor white man give me my food it
feels amazing i go
i do
oh listen listen it feels amazing when
you got money listen yeah i'll be
kicking up my photo give me the nicest
suite you got i i now know what it feels
like to be an expat in africa it feels
good breath stop okay same thing stop
get the [ __ ] up this is europe civilized
blonde haired blue eyes case you didn't
get it not bad in the telegraph and
wants to make it even more clear for you
writing quote they seem so like us that
is what it makes it so shocking ukraine
is a european country it's people watch
netflix and have instagram accounts vote
in free elections and have uncensored
newspapers war is no longer something
visited upon impoverished and remote
populations it can happen to anyone all
just seemingly a bunch of different ways
of trying to say oh my god they're
killing white people now these reporters
and analysts clearly expect that the
white american and european majorities
will care more about the humanity of
these particular victims because we
share similar levels of melanin and that
is certainly part of what's going on
here after all you do see some countries
right now opening their arms to the
white refugees of the ukraine war while
closing their doors to those from africa
and the middle east well i want to speak
on that if you guys haven't seen some of
the videos and some of this stuff
basically uh students african students
who are studying in ukraine were trying
to leave
specifically trying to get to poland and
they were not allowed on the trains it
had to be the white ukrainian men who
were to leave before the black folks
could leave even the black women were
not allowed to leave with other women
and elderly people who were on some of
the first trains there was someone who i
was talking to here earlier who tried to
get on the train and wasn't allowed to
get on the train they are only allowing
they are not allowing the blacks to get
on board
so if you are black and then you go
there you are wasting your time so we
didn't even like bother ourselves we
just went to uh take a bus
and then headed uh to this place
yeah because usually there were black
people that were already there that were
turning around
looking for the borders and other routes
because they stood there for
a long time and they were not getting on
the train because they were stopping
them so they were warning us not to even
try to go there because they would not
allow us that is why we didn't go for
the train and try to find another route
and
how does that make you feel
to hear things like that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
a black woman is seen being denied
boarding onto a train believed to be
evacuating civilians in ukraine away
from the advance of russia from the east
no verbal reason is given for the denial
but moments later a white woman is
allowed to board the same train so
there's a lot of issues in that regards
even some of the africans who decide
like listen we're not gonna wait for
train we're gonna literally walk to the
border they get to the border and
ukrainian border patrol folks are like
no you need to go back we're only
letting the ukrainians in first so a lot
of folks were basically being denied
treating as second-class citizens even
though they were supposed to be granted
the opportunity to leave now in defense
of poland what people are saying once
they arrive in poland including the
africans that once we got in warsaw we
were super well treated and taken care
of so it does not appear to be an issue
with the polish government this seems to
be an issue of the ukrainian border
patrol themselves so that's both sides
of it i i struggle with this thing i
struggle with this topic i struggle with
the news coverage and like how incessant
it is the people who want us to get on
top of it and feel like i need to do it
meanwhile it's like i always i told you
this before i have a hard time
enthusiastic defending folks who would
treat me like third class citizens when
[ __ ] hits the fan you get what i'm
saying
it's like you want me to jump all over
this but when [ __ ] hits the fan you'll
be like [ __ ] we putting ourselves on
the train yeah right
i have a hard time that's all i'm very
hard something yeah that's a that's all
i'm saying right so it's easy to see
here we should all love each other with
y'all just but i gotta stay on the back
train with everybody else while you guys
get on first and your lives matter more
i don't even get on the train right the
whole all lives matter you realize
that's not true
it's not true
you can say oh it's not true at all
it's not you remember how life matter
what happened to that not as soon as
that [ __ ] first rocket came back
they were out here marching
right
yeah so
where's the all eyes now yay
you guys in mud silence right now
and also again i've been fair i've also
said that when those folks arrived in
poland they were super well treated by
the polish people so i'm not trying to
paint a wide brush but it just really
depicts you how life is
how people have different classes
depending on where you are you know i
mean it goes like that everywhere people
are seen differently depending on how
they are who they are the skin color
that's it was really a representation of
how the world views people you know so
i'm talking about in a wire situation
wait don't talk to me about yeah but
they're getting that that's not what i'm
talking about in a war situation they
got to stay behind and they got to kill
people all right so white
woman kids black men
the rest
yeah
yeah even some indian students were also
stranded not allowed to cross the border
everybody that was nominated basically
exactly if you're not white or ukrainian
it was just like you know what
sucks to be you love to be me i hop on
the train you stay there it is what it
is i mean that's the thing is that it's
it's really hard for me to be like okay
so and be very passionate and not laugh
at it because it's some [ __ ] that we've
been known it's some [ __ ] that we've
been saying people have been saying no
it's not really like that you guys are
but now it's happening in front of you
and you're like man it's just it's just
what i said it was so it's really hard
for me to not care but yeah care it's
hard for me to care because it's been
like that you know when you're exposed
to something so
when you're exposed to something that's
my next point when you're exposed to
something so much it desensitizes you at
some point you know i mean like
we've been seeing people from around
countries getting shot getting this and
that and whatever the first time you see
a school shooter you're like oh my god
it cost me i remember the first time i
heard about school shootings i don't
remember the 399 other ones
no i mean columbine that was messed up
after that
so people are really like oh yeah
whatever syrians getting shot whatever
white people oh my god
but at the end of the day it's humans
so man
potatoes potatoes it is what it is it's
been happening in the world it's just
that i see humans i'm like yeah
these [ __ ] are suffering but i
can't really necessarily always talk
about this subject it's easier to
otherwise people who don't look like you
or have different cultural practices or
traditions or religions but melon in
solidarity
is not actually the real story here
playing to a shared racial and cultural
identity it's really just a tool it's a
means to an end that the news media is
using to persuade americans that they
should care more about the people in
this conflict than in any number of
other conflicts that they are not
covering whatsoever this is a classic
case of the phenomenon noam chomsky and
edward hermann describe in manufacturing
consent how the media picks worthy and
unworthy victims choosing which stories
protests wars famines are worthy of
coverage and worthy of displaying the
humanity of the people impacted and
which should either be ignored
completely or actively demonized and the
deciding factor here is not actually
race or culture or which continent the
events happen to be unfolding on the
deciding factor is which narratives are
most convenient for the us government
just ask yourself this question why was
it that for decades of the afghan war
the afghan civilians killed by the u.s
state were considered unworthy victims
then for a brief period during our
withdrawal from afghanistan suddenly
afghan civilians were worthy victims and
then the news media cared deeply about
the fate of the women and girls who
would live under taliban rule
then just as suddenly now that there is
a mass famine caused by our own cruel
theft of the afghan government funds
afghan civilians are once again unworthy
victims the ethnicity cultural practices
and level of development of the country
did not change what changed was which
narrative was convenient for our state
in fact within the very same country at
the very same time some victims were
deemed worthy and covered as such but
the media by the media while others were
not so victims of american drone strikes
unworthy the afghan girls robotics team
worthy all because of what the u.s state
wanted highlighted and what they wanted
suppressed it's disgraceful how the
corporate news media is happy to
manipulate americans most noble
humanitarian impulses and channel them
in directions that are convenient for
u.s power and you can see this dynamic
playing out right now all over the world
in our own country within liberal media
coveted victims have frequently been
given worthy treatment while victims of
drug overdoses have been given unworthy
treatment looking around the world cuban
protesters and hong kong protesters were
given worthy treatment since they were
opposing governments that our elites
don't like chilean protesters and
palestinian protesters were given the
unworthy treatment because the u.s state
did not care for their causes perhaps
the most glaring discrepancy right now
is between the way the ukrainian war is
being covered and the way that the saudi
war in yemen is being ignored in yemen
the u.s has been backing our allies
saudi arabia in a proxy war that has
left the yemeni population starving and
completely desperate in fact yemen is
currently considered to be the world's
worst humanitarian crisis with millions
of children in danger of starving to
death but since the us is complicit in
causing this particular war and its
attendant mass suffering you don't hear
a whole lot about it on the contrary for
all the flaws of the media's coverage of
the ukraine conflict and there are many
they have gone out of their way to treat
the people suffering there with humanity
i've watched beautiful videos and read
heart-wrenching stories about refugees
grabbing what they can and fleeing by
the hundreds of thousands about families
hunkered down in parking garages
terrified for their lives and the lives
of their children about young men
suddenly thrust in the middle of a war
with hastily issued government weapon
and zero training the play to tribalism
these blond-haired people are just like
you they watch netflix that is a
technique used in the manipulation an
effective manipulation because yes of
very real problems of racism and
tribalism but it's not actually the root
cause of that manipulation the reason
they want you to see these victims as
the fully worthy human beings that they
are is because they're opposing one of
our most significant global adversaries
now some make the opposite mistake of
thinking that since the ukrainian
suffering is convenient for the us state
that we should not care about it
whatsoever so let me be totally clear
what's being done to ukraine by russia
is horrible and it is heartbreaking and
it deserves to be covered with humanity
i don't want the coverage of ukraine to
have less care and empathy i want all
wars to be given this same treatment
this is also not a call to stop covering
the conflict i believe the stakes for
the world of what happens in ukraine as
we've been laying out here today are
very very high we are witnessing a
global great power realignment in real
time which will shape our world for
decades to come we are also watching in
real time as the worst voices in
american politics try to draw us into a
war with a nuclear power those are
serious consequential topics with global
implications and they deserve thorough
consideration but when the media tries
to convince you of the righteousness of
a particular cause because of the
humanitarian considerations just
remember all of the millions of
humanitarian considerations that they
care absolutely nothing about
that's facts
that's facts and sometimes you know we
get that criticism because folks like
why aren't you guys caring about it then
and it's like bro i ain't got time i
ain't got the energy to care about
everything
we're just two people behind the camera
if you think we can cover all these
topics and all these stories and do the
well research you are bugging i would
not have enough time in the day
i don't have time enough time to read up
on the history learn all the because
people want to make everything seem
black and white it's not simple and you
want to believe that because you're so
strongly emotionally attached issue but
it's not
so for us it's not difficult but when i
see the media doing the exact same job
that we do then i get a little bit sus
cause i'm i [ __ ] you guys are only
covering this story and forgetting
everything else that's what you do
that's your actual job
you have reporters you have a home oh
yeah you got a whole staff on deck and
you [ __ ] can't cover this [ __ ]
apparently
right and it's just it makes me feel a
little bit salty
you know because it's like oh these
people are victims that you guys are
finally worthy this is something that
you guys find appalling this invasion
but when y'all were doing these
invasions you guys didn't have the same
energy that's really no
no
because they're back by guys she's right
i have to fight myself to not turn
apathetic to what i'm seeing on the news
right now because i understand there are
people on the other end suffering even
if their border patrol has been racist
or whatever it might be i don't i have
to let that not turn me into somebody's
like well then [ __ ] up i have to do that
work okay right because it's very easy
to get into that emotion yeah it's not
i'll tell you i got a lot of black folks
i know who were like oh that's what they
do to everything
[ __ ] they don't even play oh they're
five figure points man [ __ ] that whole
continent [ __ ] you know what i mean i
pick a fight
oh yeah
i have to remind myself that right
but it
it it becomes difficult when you
constantly see just these images and
meanwhile like she said like i listen
i've been following what's been
happening in yemen that [ __ ] is tragic
it is a far worse and by far worse power
in a lot of ways than russia to me
so my thing i know this for a fact when
[ __ ] generally hits the fan if you're
not super well integrated to that
community to the point where you guys
are symbiotic listen tribalism kicks in
like this real quick tribalism kicks in
like this along family lines or racial
lines or wrong ethnic lines unlocked
nationality lines who's a refugee who's
not even the way that they talk about
these refugees they're like well these
are refugees are different they they
look like us they sound like us so we
can accept them like the news coverage
has been creepy like that man so if this
[ __ ] happens to get back you think that
you think the english people are not
going to go
back of the bus yeah this is quebec town
right here yeah i already know it's
going you know it's going to be a fight
to get on the plane yeah you know yeah
but the angles was yeah well now they're
mine already in quebec and they're
getting they're eating [ __ ] yes the
history quebecers yes in the history
y'all been been treating like [ __ ] by
anglos absolutely i give you that but
now
they're in minority and if this [ __ ]
hits the fan here they're not getting on
the train so who's getting on the train
if this [ __ ] hits canada yeah so that's
really the question that's the personal
struggle i have but i think if you ask
me on a principal standpoint of course i
think what thing was happening is
terrible people's homes are being
eradicated people's country and national
identities are trying to be stripped
from them like i understand all these
things are terrible so in that regards i
obviously sympathize obviously
but there's that struggle on the other
side and unfortunately that's a very
thing that that's real for me so
i just wanted to share those thoughts
and i think shout out to breaking points
i think they do a great job on a lot of
these topics and so i always appreciate
them they admit when they're wrong when
they get it right i always want to show
them some love so anything else you want
to say yeah man we're taking advantage
of war again
hey man i'm gonna put all the heads i
can on this you know i mean get all the
money we can all the buddy yo have you
seen that joe rogan clip which one
there's a clip on instagram from joe
rogan what do you say did he say that
make us in ukraine then people go what
that would be perfect if you didn't
[Music]
so anybody comes from me talking about
you profiting uh yeah austin cnn you can
suck my dick
enjoy some applebee's
you seen that
they put a whole ass country song in the
middle of [ __ ]
oh that's [ __ ]